[MUSIC]
I think number one benefit that
I believe is the flexibility.
I always wanted to do a MBA,
but the whole commute and
other things was a little difficult for
me.
And when these on demand courses actually
came when I was doing some research,
I felt like the time commitment was short.
It fit with my schedule really well.
And I was able to learn something new,
while not slowing down on
other aspects of my life.
>> The format of the course is
very hands on, it's very practical,
it's very structured, simple to apply.
>> The benefits of this course that
I could think about is the framework,
with which I'm thinking about the problem,
the business, the competition.
I'm definitely seeing myself apply
whatever I learned on a day-to-day basis.
And it was structured in such a way that
you got to apply a lot of thinking and
that was the fun part.
>> Every participant gets their
assignments that they have to submit to
me, they get the feedback
from the facilitators,
do some reflection with them.
>> I was very amazed at the breadth
of knowledge that the instructors
actually had in providing
very valuable feedback.
>> I was looking for
some guidance frameworks,
seeking support in that area so
that we can disrupt our own business.
With the Stanford course enabled me to
look from an outsider's point of view on
my own business.
And it enabled me to identify growth and
optimization that has been super
beneficial to me and
to the leadership team of my company.
>> If you want to learn something,
these individual courses are definitely
changing the way one can operate.
I would say just don't wait, just take it.
[MUSIC]